أمر الرئيس بايدن
المخابرات بالبحث بشكل أعمق في
أصل Covet 19 مع
التركيز مجددًا على المدينة الصينية
حيث تم اكتشافها لأول مرة
علنًا ، حيث قال البيت الأبيض إن هناك
نظريتين محتملتين للأصل
، أولهما انتشار طبيعي من الحيوانات
إلى البشر
ربما تضخم في الداخل
سوق المأكولات البحرية في ووهان المزدحم ذات مرة
، هو الاحتمال الثاني والأكثر إثارة للجدل ،
وهو تسرب الفيروس القاتل من
مختبر ووهان هذا ، ونحن نعلم أن الصين قامت بعملية
تستر واسعة النطاق بدءًا من اليوم الأول ،
بما في ذلك إتلاف العينات وإخفاء
السجلات التي تسجن الأشخاص الذين يسألون في
الصين.  الأسئلة الأساسية ووضع
أمر حظر النشر
، لقد مر أكثر من عام منذ
اندلاع المرض الأولي
وما زال لا توجد إجابات قاطعة
ادعى الرئيس السابق ترامب في الربيع الماضي
أنه بدأ في معهد ووهان
لمختبر علم الفيروسات ،
لكنه لم يقدم أبدًا دليلًا على الصينيين
جنبًا إلى جنب مع العديد من العلماء
رفض نظرية التسريب في المختبر لترامب باعتباره
رئيس مؤامرة يتسامح  ن تولى منصبه لدعم
نهج دولي في
التحقيق في الأصل
هذا الأسبوع ، أخبرت ثلاثة مصادر مطلعة
بالموضوع أن بايدن أغلق أيضًا
تحقيق وزارة الخارجية الرابحة في الأصول
بسبب مخاوف بشأن جودة
الأدلة
ولكن الآن مع المعلومات الاستخبارية التي تم الإبلاغ عنها حديثًا
هناك  أسئلة جديدة
عما عرفته الصين وعندما ذكرت مجلة وول ستريت
هذا الأسبوع أن
تقريرًا أمريكيًا من إنتل وجد أن العديد من
الباحثين في مختبر ووهان
أصيبوا بمرض شديد وكان عليهم الذهاب إلى
المستشفى في نوفمبر 2019.
أي قبل أسابيع من إعلان الصين عن
أول تقرير.  المريض الذي يعاني من أعراض شبيهة بالطمع
الذي أدى إلى
زيادة الضغط على إدارة بايدن
للعثور على إجابات
في يناير من هذا العام ، كنا في
ووهان حيث
أرسل فريق العمل الميداني فريقًا إلى الصين
للتحقيق في
زيارة السوق المغلق الآن.
لقد كانت نقطة الصفر الأصلية
، ومنذ ذلك الحين تم مسحها نظيفة ، سافرنا إليها
من قبل معهد ووهان لعلم الفيروسات
، وهو مؤمن بشدة ورفض  كانت الطلبات المتعددة
التي لم يتم منحنا الوصول إليها
للدخول ، أقرب ما يكون إلى الحد الذي
حصلنا عليه من العلماء الذين سُمح لهم
في
استنتاجهم أنه من المحتمل جدًا أن
يكون الفيروس قد انتشر بشكل طبيعي من الحيوانات
وأنه من غير المحتمل للغاية حدوث تسرب في المختبر
، ولا يوجد دليل على ذلك في  كل شيء ولكن
هذا شيء تحدثنا عنه
مع الأشخاص في مختبر ووهان وحصلنا على إجابات
صادقة
وصريحة وجيدة بالمعلومات أيضًا ،
لكن هذه هي المشكلة مع من قام
بالتحقيق وفقًا لبعض
العلماء الذين شاركوا في البحث ،
فقد اعتمد في الغالب على المحادثات
مع
أخذ العلماء الصينيون كلامهم ، واشتكى بعض
الخبراء من أن
الصين منعتهم من الحصول على بيانات مهمة
، وتعرض أولئك مثل بيتر
دازيك لانتقادات لعلاقاتهم الشخصية
بمختبر ووهان
بعد أن ساعدوا في التمويل والمشاركة في
الأبحاث في المنشأة قبل
تفشي
الفيروس.  كانت ماريان كوبمان من
بين الفريق في ووهان في يناير ،
كانت حريصة على وصف عمل الفريق
بأنه  جمع بحثي
ليس كفحص ، فهي ترحب أيضًا
بجهود بايدن للحصول على مزيد من المعلومات حول
الأصول على
أمل أن يشارك النتائج ،
فإذا كان هناك شيء جيد حقًا ،
فيجب متابعته في هذه الأثناء
تتراجع الصين عن روايتها الخاصة.
وصف المتحدث باسم الولايات المتحدة جهود الولايات المتحدة بأنها حملة تشويه
ودوافعها شريرة ، وقال المتحدث
إن المسؤولين الصينيين
دفعوا بلا هوادة لمؤامرة لا أساس لها من أن
الفيروس بدأ
في الولايات المتحدة ، لكن لا يوجد دليل على
أن
وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الصينية وصفت
الفيروس بأنه تهديد مستورد
حتى أنه لا أساس له من الصحة.  جاء من
خارج الصين
على الأطعمة المجمدة من الفوضى
والارتباك الذي حدث في الفاشية الأولية إلى
تصاعد الذعر مع ارتفاع عدد الوفيات بسبب
انتشار الفيروس
إلى الآمال في أن اللقاحات قد
تعيدنا إلى الحياة
19 ما زلنا نتساءل
كيف  فعل كل هذا حقا بدأ ديفيد
كلفر سي إن
شنغهاي